- "Cells at Work!" season one
told us how the body works.
"Cells at Work!" season
two CODE BLACK tells us
what we do to our bodies and
how we hurt them, peewoop!
Episode 1: Smoking, Bacteria,
and the Beginning of the End.
I hope it's not the beginning of the end.
(speaking in foreign language)
(student yawns)
This is so funny because not
only is this very accurate
in that an immature red
blood cells and erythroblasts
and now that they become red blood cells,
they are fully matured.
They are also presenting this
like a true med school
situation where some people
in the classroom are
sleepy and yawning, me.
Some people are taking notes
and being very aggressive.
What do we know about red blood cells?
Main job is to carry
oxygen throughout the body
and deliver it to its vital tissues:
brain, the lungs, the heart, kidneys.
These are vital organs that keep us going.
In fact, if blood vessels,
the little tunnels that red
blood cells travel through,
are ever blocked, that's
when you have a problem.
If one of those arteries
or blood vessels starts to
get blocked in the heart,
you have a heart attack.
One of them gets blocked in
the brain, you have a stroke.
It's all about maintaining good plumbing
and allowing these red
blood cells to do their job.
So I hope they're paying attention.
(speaking in foreign language)
(laughs) Oxygen/O2.
Aw.
Red blood cells, unfortunately,
all they do is circulate
throughout the body
no matter what time of
day it is, day/night.
When a person's sleeping,
you're still circulating blood.
You got to feed the brain,
you got to recover the
muscles, all that good stuff.
Now that being said,
red blood cells are only
around approximately 120 days.
And throughout that time,
they're constantly getting refreshed
and new ones are being made.
(speaking in foreign language)
Basically when the aortic
valve opens, the heart beats
and all the red blood cells
starts shooting out to the body.
Whether they go to the top
of the body in the brain
or to the bottom of the body
to the kidneys and legs, et cetera.
The goal is to get as much oxygen quickly
to that part of the body
and then to bring back the red blood cells
that are now deoxygenated
and need to be refreshed by the lungs
back through the venous system.
Now I know a lot of times
in textbooks we draw the
arterial system is red
and the venous system is blue.
If you cut someone's veins,
I promise the blood is still gonna be red.
It's just simply about
the tint of the blood
when it's below your skin, but in reality,
it is still red, I promise.
(speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic music)
Platelets.
Oh, does this person have an ulcer?
An ulcer is an opening inside the stomach
from the gastric acid
or perhaps an infection
and as a result, bleeding can occur.
(speaking in foreign language)
(magma bubbling)
I would make a small correction there.
It's not the first stage of digestion
because the first stage of digestion
is a funny word known as mastication.
Mastication is when you chew,
that is the chemical breakdown of food,
that is where digestion begins.
In fact, you have salivary
amylase which is an enzyme
that starts breaking down
sugars inside the food
that you're eating
immediately in your mouth.
In your mouth. That's right.
So digestion is happening here first.
That's the first step of
digestion not in the stomach.
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, wow. Angry stomach.
(suspenseful music)
Can you imagine if every time
you didn't take care of your body,
you underslept, you
overworked, overate, underate,
ate something unhealthy,
overdrank, smoked a cigarette,
did something wrong in general
that your body's cells
actually went on strike
and got mad at you?
Imagine your stomach was like, "I'm mad.
Stop working.
Agh.
(pipe explodes)
(both gasp)
Oh no!
(man coughing)
(man gasping)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh no, carbon monoxide poisoning.
(suspenseful music)
This is a very accurate description
of how carbon monoxide
poisoning actually happens.
Because it has a higher affinity,
meaning it's more likely to
bind with this red blood cell,
it actually blocks the
ability to carry oxygen.
So what happens if you have a slow leak
of carbon monoxide into a small area,
like a garage or a home, you
actually start getting sleepy,
you get a little nauseous, a
headache starts developing,
and what's really dangerous is
if you do end up falling
asleep, you could die.
Also, knowing that the treatment
for carbon monoxide poisoning,
if you get to the hospital,
is getting a full blast
of O2 in your face.
Why?
Because if you overload the amount
of oxygen you're getting,
hopefully that will
create enough competition
that your red blood
cells will actually get
some of this oxygen as opposed
to the carbon monoxide.
Does that make sense?
(foot thuds)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh pneumococci!
(bacteria growling)
So this is why whenever
a patient is diagnosed
with bacterial pneumonia,
one of the first things we do
is institute antibacterial
treatment with antibiotics.
The invention of antibiotics
has really gone a long way
in extending life and
preventing unnecessary death.
However, now we're kind of in this state
where we're overusing antibiotics
and are not only killing healthy bacteria
in our bodies by mistake
that we need to live,
but also you can create resistance,
where if you don't take antibiotics
for a long enough period of time,
or let's say you take them
and you eradicate 99% of the bacteria,
you leave the 1% that are
genetically resistant to it.
And as a result, when they reproduce,
each time you take the antibiotics,
your body bacteria actually
start building up a resistance
to those antibiotics.
Why does that become
problematic? Well, guess what?
A patient comes in with a pneumonia,
let's say a sepsis where the
bacteria is now in the blood,
and then you realize for
all the antibiotic options
that you have, which we
don't have millions of,
you actually have no choices
on what to give that patient
because all the bacteria is resistant
and you've created a superbug.
This thing looks like a superbug
but I hope antibiotics will
still work in this case.
(dramatic music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(metal clangs)
(bodies thud)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh!
That white blood cell got some moves.
Reminds of Michonne from "Walking Dead."
Who's a "Walking Dead" fan here?
(speaking in foreign language)
It's funny that they're
going to the carotid artery,
there was some plaque there visible.
This does happen, and in fact,
one of the causes or
potential causes of strokes is
when you have such a bad
occlusion of the carotid arteries,
you actually impede
blood flow to that area.
So imagine if you have a lot
of plaque, it's blocked off,
you can't get blood to the
brain, boom, stroke happens.
Now you do have two carotid arteries
which makes it a little bit better.
So you wanna keep your
carotid arteries as patent
and as open as possible,
and how do you do that?
Living a healthy lifestyle,
going for preventive screenings,
making sure your cholesterol
is under control,
and know that just because
your cholesterol is high
or the LDL cholesterol,
the bad cholesterol is
high, it doesn't mean
that you might necessarily
be doing something wrong
because there are cases where
genetics play a huge role
so much so that your
cholesterol is so high
that you could never even get
it that high with a bad diet
as a result of your genetics.
This is known as familial
hypercholesterolemia.
There are specific medications
that are recently been released
called PCSK9 inhibitors.
Again, we don't like
jumping to medications
but if you have such a dangerous LDL
that it's causing you a risk
to have a premature heart
attack at a young age,
maybe it's worth being on that medication.
(speaking in foreign language)
(ominous music)
Smoking is bad for you.
I don't feel like I need to
say that but at the same time,
I'm gonna because I want you to know
that smoking increases
risk of not only cancers,
not just lung cancer, all cancers,
like so many cancers throughout your body,
other lung diseases like COPD,
chronic bronchitis, emphysema.
increases in heart disease, strokes.
Just by smoking,
we lose approximately half a million lives
due to smoking in the
United States every year.
We in the medical community know
that cigarettes contain
over 600 ingredients
and when you light them
on fire and burn them,
that creates over 7,000 chemicals
that you're inhaling into your body.
And while nicotine may make
you feel good temporarily,
it goes away and it's
highly, highly addictive.
It's one of the most
addictive things out there.
That's why it's so dangerous.
(speaking in foreign language)
(ominous music)
I hope this episode helps
you quit smoking if you do.
If you're not gonna do it for yourself,
do it for these little red blood cells.
They don't deserve the stress
that we're putting on them.
Quit smoking and if you need
help, talk to your doctor
'cause we actually have so many
options of helping you quit.
Not only from a behavioral
therapy perspective,
we have some medications that can help,
group counseling, et cetera.
Talk to your doctor.
If you have that motivation,
share it with us and we'll
be happy to help you out.
This is a great medical show.
These are bad medical games,
like really bad, embarrassingly
bad one-star games.
Click that to check me playing them.
Checking me playing them?
Check me out playing them.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)